oh my god yeah get yo get run run yo
again rod Oh
move move move in Minecraft morning to
you fellas top of the morning today we
are starting off the game outside that's
because I downloaded the pewdiepie pack
thanks one of you fellow nine-year-olds
have made another super duper request is
that I use shaders and I have and I
never seen it before so this is the
first time I am looking at shaders in
Minecraft it's very epic and as you can
see here it says minecraft EURion
edition what pewdie crack yeah yeah yeah
hopefully this doesn't break my save
file
Oh Jurgen you look so good my god oh
wait I have extra gold oh gosh how did
this happen I was who the Freak are you
imposter I can barely see the water look
so pretty my god don't ever look at me
again
damn this is weird
oh my god they're wiggling they're
wiggling Jurgen sled
let me look at you my god you're cute
you look the same
ah yeah okay let me look at you wow look
it's a beautiful using this lens flare
my god my god so as you can see there's
there's a couple changes I'll be playing
a lot like a lot like I didn't want to
get ahead so I've just been that is move
on its own
I just been there building stuff so I
built this temple for Walter sheep it's
a water temple
so there's water flowing everywhere I
spent a long time on this ok a very long
time
oh my god it's for water shape of course
of course I have to do it to him and the
idea is that the water flows from the
water church into any it feeds it feeds
my crops
thank you what they're sheep
you are gone but not forgotten so the in
this church all the sheeps get to walk
free and where are they come back here
scumbag you're supposed to be free oh my
god I think come down from there how did
this happen
oh my god oh no sorry oh my god that
mean he just wants to go up again no
he's escaping kill him
what at 20 fps in here don't think so
coward be free all right let me let me
jump back into the regular one that's
cool
shaders is cool okay don't get me wrong
way I got a restart the game yeah so I
don't know Shane there's this cool and
no don't you dare even think about it
I'm trying to be nice to you I built you
this home don't get me wrong it's just
that I've done 12 episodes I don't want
to just change midway through isn't that
right that's right
I also built this minecart so the svenne
can ride to his house go in spend oh my
god he has an armor I didn't think about
getting spent oh my god Felix and Jurgen
- and Sven that is so sure I think that
pity pie pack that's fun right I just
think it's too much with the shaders
listen I'm I'm a tasteful guy what can I
say
get in oh my god
said no I was look at me
don't worry about it he'll come back I
think it's been here he comes
did you have a good right smell with
that fun heck yeah
all right all right so today we have a
lot of adventures I want to head out and
do some stuff that we haven't done
before but yeah it's looking clean like
I really like my area I'm thinking about
maybe I build something in here one
episode like the enchantment room will
be built inside the trees like a tree
Hut
that could be cool I have ideas guys I
have ideas I have a health part in
melons
whoa I don't know that was possible
oh yeah I fixed that I fixed now so it's
a button cuz everyone kept asking me to
do a button instead so there you go it's
always great whenever I build or do
something everyone's like wow that's so
cool and then someone else just goes
sick of mode and makes it like 10 times
better and I'm like are cool I was proud
of that but I guess you can do it better
huh okay I want to build a redstone for
my farm I want to I'm getting tired of
always farming I'm getting tired of
always doing all this hard work isn't
that right key idea bird claws oh my god
I haven't named you I'm so sorry I just
realized and this is also definitely the
same IKEA bird as the last time and I
did not accidentally kill him while I
was killing zombies he flew right in
front of me what am I supposed to do I
didn't name the first one there doesn't
matter
I like IKEA bread more than cloth
because everyone thinks cloths means
Klaus and which it isn't you dummies
it's like a bird now learn it being
binding being bound we're gonna build
redstone contraptions for the farm I
don't know how you do it I just know you
came everyone's been saying I should do
it I imagine I just use piston let's try
it out gamers do you think it's possible
to not get sidetracked in Minecraft I
said I gotta call the record today I
guess it'll be like semi-automatic I'll
still have to like press a button
so it's just like like that and then
that makes it go what can you guys I'm
trying to think I'm trying to think oh
my gosh
please replanting or at least do ah as
punishment you stay with water sheep
guard him my god it's you a nice man
okay oh wait how would I do it then if
you put water yeah oh my god he does and
he collects them as well that's genius
okay we can do this ven too lazy to go
back to the house so the idea is water
will come it will flow all the way it
will collect I might have to move this I
can't just move Spence rollercoaster he
loves it
oh well too bad sorry scent it's he
replaced I will rebuild it don't worry
and then we put slabs all the way so
there's no leakage
I know this ruins the beautiful metaphor
oh my gosh that's perfect how part is it
water run oh that is looking good damn
so here wait how do I stop the water
wait oh yes I forgot I need actual
redstone wait okay okay this is becoming
more and more complicated what am i
dying meanwhile people are building
computers in Minecraft Swedish boy tries
to make farming simulator very epic I'm
building this for the future in mind
because I want to them all connected
right yes yes okay cool can barely tell
it's there it doesn't look as dramatic
but I think it works let it go let it
flow yeah dude we're scientists then
yes now I think we need hoppers hoppers
hoppers nope in his chest
ah expensive I don't know how these work
in before a million comma K okay forget
I asked
ship ship ship ship ship ship I only
loved one sheep in my life why I have to
have vengeance upon the others look I
know how to I know how to do chest from
from brain look chefs from brain chefs
from brain boys nice try big brain very
big brain span chefs from brains I have
chest from brains
I have shift from my brain okay so now
the items will plop is Snoopy into the
hoppy let's give it a try
blop blip blop blip blop okay do I just
toss some some meat it goes in and bam
it worked what wait this one doesn't
work what is this one go in and not that
one ah useless well and now we get the
bone meat bone meat Bing bong Bing bong
bone and wheat rocky bones I know how to
make bone meat from scratch Bing bong
Bing bong Bing alright you can come now
I fine Bing bong Bing bong bing bang
bong Bing bong found me mean my mom are
we ready to get married today IKEA bird
let's do D
[Music]
it's kind of gone on the side a little
bit but it's fine
some of it went inside no ok that's
easily fixed come on obviously I still
have to replant I don't know if there's
a way to oh my god
aim to make it automatic - oh my gosh
that's some real big brain action whoa
neat phone me don't question the science
behind bone me okay then let's go don't
fall on the sides please it still kind
of falls on the side dang it
perfection is all that I asked for it
ain't much no ooh
see if it was this height I would be
very satisfied
I guess I can just build it further down
ah big brain you know maybe these
redstone things at the start of the
video isn't isn't the best idea guys
Auto jump on what the this whoa hey it's
leaking oh my god test number five let's
go oh my a work beautifully oh I love it
I'm so happy so there you have it folks
it's pretty clean and the rewiring will
be easy when I connect it all into one
some spell but you know what that's life
maybe I'll do a button okay relax I'll
do a button and the best part about it
spends roller coaster still works baby
oh yeah
how are we doing up here sheeps having a
great time farming Spanish back yeah
where did he spawn in the wall
I forgot because there's a new skin
[Music]
no one escapes no one escapes back off
back off back off I never hesitate to
kill a child
I'll never I just learned
great now I have to get more cows how
did you there is confusion hundred
tropical fish spruce born coral sounds
kinky
okay fine one more it's it's time for
epic Sven and Juergen adventure it's
time again what their sheep needs a new
sacrifice the night's the night strikes
12:00
Oh water sheep give us guidance give us
hope
show us the way what their sheep and
accept this humble offering oh wait
sorry I forgot Oh what their sheep
please accept our offer ring damn you're
stronger than I thought what the Sheep
what's happening
are you there what the Sheep
okay
IKEA's bird what did you do IKEA's bird
cannot run both this makes no sense but
what this states what I care about where
did you find this The Creeper was a
warning
go to the West in the desert for your
next
bah-bah what'she hey that's meant what
the sheep is still listening it means we
must ride out it's the weirdest
playthrough I don't need oh my god ya
get ya get
run run yet again move move move ah make
a buck then they said oh my gosh are you
okay always fine make a button yeah well
okay old makeup I'll rewire the loo like
a puddin cheap early bus when you soon
IVA redstone is gonna be the death of me
damn Jurgen - got that armor why does
water sheep want me to go east we ride
in the darkness we ride in the rain
where does water sheep leave me Oh keep
get excited nothing beats an adventure
with the boys
ow every time I try to do something oh
my god it's a year against girlfriend
I'm kidding look at this okay I've seen
this from a distance man but I've been
too scared I've been too scared to
approach it follow me Sven what is this
place it's this where water sheep was
born this is hometown
are you his mother whoa whoa whoa look
at this bridge I don't like this place
gosh okay let's put you down cool hey
where's Finn okay did it happen again
what on God's earth is there el what
happened to you
yeah can I drink your titty milk oh damn
damn heat is good what he Stace
what the Frick it's regular dirt but it
looks so different this is your weird
Island there's a ship out there whoa
whoa whoa there's got a little oasis
here you guys want a break
do they make mushroom babies mushroom
baby that's awesome that's so cool they
can make more
can we eat mushroom I need silk touch I
think yeah we look so gross
then minecraft is full with so many
surprises I'm always like what's the
next thing you're gonna find what is
they what do I do here what is the point
why did water sheep sent me here are you
thinking
are you thinkin what I'm thinkin smen
that's right
that's right we're gonna bring you home
here with us now please fine you have no
choice get in
Sven I'm sorry but you're gonna have to
know I know you don't want to go with
them I know you think it's weird but you
have to come here oh god I'm a little
scared whoa yeah I like your style
mushroom cow whoo man I'm always so good
at naming stuff get it's red oh wait you
can't fit okay
it's fine you gotta stay stay with the
yes perfect Jurgen we're bringing him
home we all decided sorry you don't get
to vote so I've seen other people put
their horse in a freaking boat so I'm
putting my horse
in the frickin boat get there again I
know what you feel about water but get
in boat
get in the boat how can everyone else
get there yergin in their boat this is
so unfair
guys it's getting dark I'm scared just
getting both thank you
seriously I need you in the boat guys
the boat the boat is for me
let's ride oh yeah they love it oh don't
hit my cow don't hit my cow this doesn't
seem like a bad idea at all feeling okay
cool why didn't you glad we agree
what is that sound does that mean he
just bought sorry guys
why is it dolphin freaking start there
she is the beauty reveals itself
what dolphin dolphin no don't feel I
save you
dolphin I save you don't feel I tried to
rescue your life idiot what are you
doing
freak is wrong with dolphins spent what
are you doing oh my god are you okay get
away from me Oh Mike is he in no no okay
that's your new home your again you
couldn't fit in a boat but he who fit in
there mine car okay okay wait wait oh my
gosh it's so unstable get it cuz it's a
horse can we do your again have fun why
is that i thing what's up like a bird Oh
what are you up to
cool is he coming back he's coming back
oh my gosh the amount of time I try to
get him in a boat how does an Pig oh my
gosh that means he can ride the this one
Oh Mike
okay can we do this no he jumps out
such a dumb idea Khmer you're a bigot
doing it move move your again
go get your giddyap oh my god oh my god
oh my god
man where are you going
go